guys i have a really cool outfit
underneath this but not saved the day
because i am cold up here on this
rooftop you know
global warming is crazy because then one
day it's 100 and then one day it's 50
what is the day it really is it was 80
degrees this morning and now it's like
40 degrees right now and we're freezing
but not you know not not because because
of you i'm good
all right let's talk about it america
because of you i'll never freeze on
american idol rooftop
yeah you know it's true
i mean it was bad but yours was really
bad it means a lot coming from you
though it really does not gonna go to
hollywood matt but you are gonna be
a really good mate for someone well
america this is your top 14. america's
picked their 10. you all have picked
your four where's your head at how do
you feel about the group
you know we picked our four and it was
unanimous so
which is great because this season's
been a little bit interesting in that
we've had some real uh public spats uh
over a few contestants like sam moss and
grace franklin and i didn't really agree
with them and you know those boys like
it's true they may have been like a
little bullied by my just like direct
black and white yes or no these whole
you know past seasons that they were
like we're not going to take it anymore
um which is fine you know but i i'm
really proud of it i i do think
that um american idol is a whole
different show and game and
challenge
you know now than it ever was and i feel
like
every season artists see us and they are
trusting us more and more so they're
kind of like inching towards us every
season more and more so
you know even this season we've got like
people tonight
saying two original songs and we love
that we love the artist because we know
that you know it's not called american
singer it's called american idol so it's
nice if they have a lot a little of you
know all the boxes
[Music]
[Music]
does it hurt a contestant or do you love
it when they sing one of your songs do
you feel like you're like a sharper eye
and a sharper ear on the people singing
your music well i definitely have a
perspective it's kind of like you've got
to like you got to sing it and interpret
it in a different way you know you have
to reinvent it or you got to sing it and
sing it so well that you put it to bed
that i can't sing it again you know and
that's happened i mean
it happened before even on this show um
and i i love it it's obviously like if
my songs mean anything to anyone and
then i'm feeling like i've done my job
and
god bless i'm i'm happy i feel like i
see stress on the judge's faces as much
as the contestant when it comes to
eliminating and picking and all of it i
get like tonight i had like a little bit
of a headache i don't know if it's pms
or what but i was like touching like you
know you know stress comes out in
different ways on your body and when i
get stressed out i just get like little
just a little bit of pain here and there
and i so i was like having to hold
myself in here because
i'm i am really invested
in all of these kids and their futures
and it's and it's like yeah some of them
go away but like this big freaking deal
it's like a real
it's a real like
it's a real opportunity in life and you
know i really hope that the ones that
had to go home tonight that they're
they're not so disappointed but they're
like there's fire behind them because
top the the top 20 is already so
stupidly talented it's really what you
do with it there's so much
you know there it does feel like there's
a lot of this is like a mentorship show
for the future of the music industry
because
maybe they win or they don't and but
maybe in like four years they're
they're all of a sudden they pop up on
the radio you're like oh i remember this
person on idle a few seasons ago and
they're finally they finally turned that
into something they either went to the
studio started writing you know like met
the right person got the right hook up
but like they never gave up and we got
to give them a little you know a little
liftoff i think it's important and i
think they appreciate your critiques and
the opportunity they have with you guys
you know that's what i hope so i mean
you know the real world out there is
is not
easy and you can't be too soft you got
to be i like to be firm and fair and you
know fun and and and hopeful and
supportive
but you know don't lie to them because
they need the help i
you know i i keep people around me that
tell me no all the time and or debate me
all the time and that's really a real
big key to success
[Music]